[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's
[Music]
it's
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can save up to retirement
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no
[Music]
grocery bags
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can save up to
[Applause]
wall bridge retirement never on fire
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
strange
[Music]
i forgot the slurp
[Laughter]
nailed it
made some movies i'm not proud of
[Laughter]
ahoy everyone that's a great start and
welcome to louder with crowder with dave
great all right
still dave yeah we are uh i just want to
make sure i'm still me yeah
sorry we were a little bit late today uh
i know some of you guys get a little uh
uppity in the feed so you know why don't
you calm down
so uh still out gotta go ahead and
scroll the audience immediately
we love you and we keep them do we just
want we just want you to love us back
you can't say uppity anymore dave no bye
you can't well you didn't say the other
part no okay yeah oh we're good oh i
just thought it was a word that meant uh
uptight oh yeah
yeah tight yeah there we go i like that
up tight uptight
uptight is all right don't get wha what
was it uh i'll get all wee weed up don't
get don't get like that who said that to
you
former president actually
was he talking about his pants well no
uh
anyway today we got gerald day of course
in studio how are you sir uh good hi
ahoy to you yeah ahoy ahoy we got
tokunawan uh-oh ahoy we got keegan
michael key bump
there you go
tim the tool man how are you sir how you
doing yeah i'm good i can't complain and
of course one of my favorite people
crawdaddy himself there it is again how
are you thank you i feel like you're
going to hit me every time i say this
so it seems to be working i don't know
it's a good nickname i'm telling you it
sounds like you're a louisiana mob boss
when i say that okay ah you know what i
mean feels better like you don't want to
see that crawdaddy no
once he comes by he mean didn't it he
meant it
what did he say he took my thumb
i can't do anything now
as far as you know we are a live show
monday through thursday at 10 a.m ish
eastern uh we are on rumble podcast mug
club all that good stuff and today
question of the day
what's your favorite thing about white
people that's not triggering
so go ahead what could go wrong there go
ahead why don't you smash that like
button right now and leave a comment
what is your favorite thing about white
people
money is that what we're supposed to
take away from that gosh
how how easily they'll let you take
their shoes ah
so i have people
so smash that like button and also uh we
got some shows coming yeah dave well
you're march 25th at the ames center in
uh burnsville in minnesota right that's
right so that's gonna be fantastic make
sure you go online and get that info and
tickets yeah my buddy matt mcclary will
be with me yeah and stephen crowder a
good friend of mine i don't know if you
know that you may have heard of him uh
april 16th we've just added a show to
the royal oak music theater in royal
lake michigan a 4 p.m show because that
sold out rather uh quickly it did yeah
so check out
louderwithcrowder.com for all your other
dates those areas should just be thawing
out around end of march right around
wearing shorts and 40 degree weather
because it's sunny washing their car
that's true yes we're done with winter
oh yeah it'd be 32 degrees and you're
golfing in shorts oh you're loving it i
remember the days you're like wearing a
sweatshirt and shorts and like oh this
is great sun feels so good you get to
hit the new potholes
after nine months of clouds that's the
thing people don't talk about don't you
miss the change of seasons i don't miss
nine months of clouds yeah yeah there's
really no seasons it's just depression
all the time and then there's like eight
days where you're like i don't wanna die
today oh that's great that's why they
bring you in for some levels perhaps
i'll go for a jog
and then you you don't you just end up
staying inside and watching tv on the
only beautiful day you get
like dave landau's in town that helps
yes yes we'll go see this guy come out
to the relic music theater yeah now i
don't know if you guys know this uh
february black history month yeah so
we'd like to share with you some black
history facts um yeah you got to break
it down that was terrible yeah because
it just pulled the stinger off me right
away well i mean you didn't hear the
music coming no
just as you were showing your favorite
thing about white people rhythm yeah i
know exactly yes thanks dave
i also sing well too and i don't dance
no even at weddings or anything i'm like
i'm not going out i used to break dance
did you i did for real for real for real
well were you any good at it no no i
would have your own piece of linoleum or
did you use a box top what did you do uh
no i just would do it at parties and
level on the floor no no i
i was very drunk it was okay it didn't
matter simply to get a laugh it burns
yeah
yeah
no dave if you don't take your pants off
it won't happen okay sometimes well
sometimes i would
i would have a cardboard box and no
pants
and now the best man with the toast dave
yeah he is
get up dave hello everyone
he's not wearing pants why why does he
do this
on every special occasion
he's a sick man
that's the 17th time i've seen his i
don't like pants okay they're leg
prisons
well let's go ahead and share these
facts
uh crawdaddy would you mind sharing
number one i could read it in 1908 jack
johnson became the first
african-american man to hold the world
heavyweight champion
boxing title really yeah wow
this is steven's wheelhouse yeah
right so in august of 1936 jesse owens
shocked the nazi germany by winning four
gold medals at the berlin olympic games
meant to uh promote the aryan race as
being superior whoops wow bad ideas
well
that may be but the greatest black
athlete of all time larry bird wow so
there you go these have been
black history facts
all right that's funny you guys chose
the larry bird
maybe the uh
the control center can find uh isaiah
thomas comments about larry bird where
he said if he were black he'd be just
another basketball player
really find it guys yep it was
scandalous back then larry bird's the
real deal you don't say that about him
no he was amazing yeah magic johnson had
this great uh there's a documentary on
him where they were talking about larry
bird and when he went to meet him he
didn't realize he was white
and he was like oh wow and he's like
that dude was for real like one of the
toughest players he ever played there
was that famous poster of him diving
to save a ball
and he said that the line is i just hate
it when they let it go out of bounds
can you imagine yeah you're a guy you
pay that much diving into the stands
just to save a a loose ball yeah he was
a competitor
thousands of dollars for floor seats
don't like their foot you know in their
eyes so yeah
it just hits jack nicholson's stupid
sunglasses
just just corn doggy seating
how did you die well
i was floor side at the lakers bird was
in town
oh man i love jordan verse bird on
nintendo i don't know if you ever played
that no that was always a good game he
looks to me for gaming yeah there was
also a generation there was also magic
versus aids it wasn't a fun game
i had pong yeah i'd let you win
it was weird a was continued to play the
game and b was stop having sex with so
many individuals
and you always hit a i don't know why
yeah there was it was a preventative
game and you your only option was no it
was choose your own invention
it's like but this is only one adventure
why not try aids
i love that that was a diet pill
and
a diet disease
well makes you
mmm been right before so that's good
coco is it do you have coco no
vitamin stuff every
vitamin stuff that desk gets two mugs
one has some something tasty and i only
get water
you don't deserve either okay thank you
you're welcome you're lucky you get
bread and water that's all you get
like like my my mother would tell me i
would get in prison
ah she was go if you go to jail you just
get bread and water and then i went to
jail and i was like you get more than
that but it's not good
yeah there are other things yeah i'm a
liar and speaking of jail
it was way better than your room beneath
the stairs yeah in detroit like other
things
yeah perfect that's better than this
place
well i don't know if you guys have seen
this uh show time
put out this new series called
everything's gonna be all white oh boy
it's extremely racist to be honest
really really uncomfortable
i enjoy what annoys me most about white
people is when they pretend like they're
the victim
[Music]
what's also annoying is when they you
know when they kill us
what is fragile about whiteness when
everything has been constructed around
it
every part of who i am has been
distorted or criminalized it's really
just a bunch of white lies
we're starving the capital
you're not patriots you're ridiculous
one of the definitions of american
whiteness is
ignorance
white people we are not your problem
you are should white people today feel
any responsibility for slavery
[Music]
hell yeah
why jesus or black jesus jesus was not
white think of jesus
neither
white culture fears the end of the world
for us as native people the end of the
world already happened like multiple
times
it's called defeated how are you talking
symbols and monuments these are mementos
of racism bring that statue that
what about tcby yogurt or something
everybody can get behind
the truth has to be told about
history have to make sure that these
stories are told from our perspective
there's always hope if you google
p-o-c-p-o-v i think different videos
this is a wild place y'all it's a wild
place i know harriet and frederick be up
there just like
what is they gonna do
speak for uh nevermind
was it journal no
this is terrible this is just absolutely
nothing but land mines i know i just
can't wait to watch tv in the future
[Laughter]
more programming like this dave is on
its way i know that's what i've heard
actually and it's the entertainment
business and there's always similar
companies trying to compete
and uh there is actually a project and
it comes from the hallmark channel oh
good it's premiering its very own series
on race
pretty fly for a white lie
[Music]
black people i mean
nothing really i mean i love black
people i voted for obama i mean i didn't
vote i would have voted for obama but
well uh
oh geez i mean i like blackbeard
well uh i mean i would have voted for
obama a third time i guess if i had to
pick one thing
maybe just in movie theaters if you
could not talk so loud now now if it's
medea's halloween go crazy i mean i get
it it's hilarious but if it's the new
tom hanks picture i mean i just like to
kind of enjoy that with my sweetheart so
you know i do get nervous when my
overweight nurse has six inch press on
nails one small thing i just asked that
you just don't push my grandma my
harmony in front of the train again
i do want to apologize for some of the
modern inconveniences that we might have
caused um
for example
airplanes electricity modern medicine
can be pretty expensive um
calculus
clothes i guess
when i'm filling up my tank could you
please just not yell hey yo white [ __ ]
democracy can get kind of rough
uh
space travel maybe on a job application
you don't put under prior work
experience
we was kangs
i've been supporting myself through
college tipping would be nice who knows
what's out there we could have like
aliens or like the moon could
explode they're just i you know we put
that on you so
i do apologize for that
saw your son today uh
maybe give him a call i think he'd
really appreciate it
[Laughter]
always pushing the other yeah it's crazy
new yeah it's actually way way less
offensive than the other one but we're
gonna get in more trouble
that's absolutely true i i mean it looks
like a good series i think both will
have their points i would watch the
second one hallmark is not my favorite
channel but i would watch no very white
channel though
what really
hallmark have you seen it yeah of course
subtle whites it's sort of like the
do-it-yourself channel which is now the
waco texas couple channel ah yeah where
they just come in and they're like you
should open up your house i feel like
dean cain owns a whole lot of hallmark
now too so i think he does love him for
it but you know did that young white guy
use the term picture referring to a
movie
tom hanks
yeah
see yeah come on come to the picture
show the picture it's not going to be a
nick you want to be in pictures kid ah
come on it's a double feature
just don't talk
we have nothing to do it's 1958. go
ahead it can't heckle it it's not live
let's go to the ball game sit in the hot
hot sun watch a man in an all-wool suit
into 800 degrees yeah racist things at
jackie robinson
oh my god you're absolutely right we're
going to take more heat for that than
showtime or whoops whoever's doing
things
i know a couple of comics and the other
one you know it's all a joke but you
know people get pissed because you know
you can only make jokes when they're
well i just found out from that one i'm
responsible for slavery so
well the other one not ours you know i
think slavery is a terrible thing of
course i'm just not i just want to say
that it is absolutely
i mean unless you're on the the profit
side then it's it's it's pretty good i
mean it's like 100 percent profit
it's a terrible thing right terrible
removing labor costs yeah
yeah oh you mean we didn't don't pay
people ah yeah oh they can't do that
it's a great idea
so
it just makes common sense amazon's
coming as close as they can well
they're trying their hardest now
unfortunately there's stuff going on
that it does involve slavery though like
you know child trafficking oh a serious
problem in this country
and uh recently a woman had a demonic
freak out really yeah after being
arrested at the border for human
smuggling
this is nacho day
him now oh she's got some strength
that's pcp
[Music]
is that latin oh oh gosh
satan be careful those warby parkers i
believe she's latin but the language is
english
the power of christ compels you protect
those ray-bans yeah exactly
i like how he tries to not hurt the
sunglasses that's right like we'll make
sure to get these back together because
look designer i like those are nice stop
it she traffic's children the demon
won't need them no of course not
well we actually found out where she
worked and was selling these people out
of unfortunately and uh we do have some
footage of that
oh boy
yellow we got hot food
my favorites pumpkin pie what do you
like i'm not really sure what they're
advertising good to see clint howard
still working
[Laughter]
i think
i think she looks better with the
mustache
i mean honestly if you had the woman we
just saw in the video and cheech marin
yeah i'm going to take a stab at cheech
[Laughter]
and i've met cheech choose wisely
i met tommy chong i i opened for tommy
chong get this guy
he was high the whole time no i'm like
be a professional who could have seen
that coming these people are paid to see
you what if they find out you're lit
that's these weren't characters
actually they're no no actually they
actually did smoke pot
did you imagine being upset by that and
not understanding anyone
honey we are leaving
i can smell this no need this man is
stoned yeah hi this is my eyes i thought
they were acting
this man it's clearly
clearly high unbelievable we're leaving
i've never seen one of his pictures
again let's go to watch a dean kane
hallmark movie
[Laughter]
dean's not here how many puppies can
save christmas
depends oh yeah
you guys heard of singapore it's a place
yeah it definitely is a place have you
been
never no no never wanted to go it would
cane me that's true
i've been have you been to singapore i
have that's cool what like a sex tourism
or what'd you do no actually i was
fighting human trafficking in uh
cambodia and then we went down there to
meet some people and raised some money
to do that david did you really that's
actually 100 percent true
he's better than you david wow
i went down there for the same reason i
mean not fighting it the other way
he fought more of a client the urge
i was i was kind of fighting you guys
i knew you looked familiar
get out of here oh man how did you do
that did you just go into a brothel and
just
unload oh no on the no no no no no no no
i couldn't do that they took me through
the area in fact we were in uh
sihanoukville which is over on you know
close to thailand and then uh we went to
ankara as well so those are two big
areas for it and uh they're like yeah at
night this place right here will be full
of people and i was they're like you
should come down here nobody will stop
you just so you can see it and it's like
no i'm gonna end up dying because wow
i'm gonna see some you know
eight-year-old girl being uh exactly and
i was just like i'm not gonna be able to
walk away and i'll die oh man did you
save some no well not that was well good
job the goal was not to actually go and
physically look i don't have a specific
set of skills okay i'm just going to
walk in we actually set up housing six
five white guys out of there yeah who's
gonna notice so yeah i shouldn't say
i have a very particular set of specific
set of skills it's not this
[Laughter]
and
enjoy her it's being stabbed by 75 men
as i walk in unarmed
being beaten by a sex cartel
wasn't it singapore where the kid threw
some gum in the street and was going to
get pain he got caned no he did get
yeah because the uh the leader emperor
whatever it was at the time had stepped
in gum and so he outlawed it i chewed
gum on a train and people were looking
at me
really this american's about to get it
the most risky thing you can do
bubblicious yeah everybody was parting
like moving away from me
sex trafficking trafficking okay but
yeah
you don't want to catch a beating on
accident i don't know oh yeah look at
this see
why they banned chewing gum yeah can you
imagine you step in chewing gum and the
rest of the country has to pay for that
yeah exactly
oops it happens haven't you ever owned
shoes well well kim jung owns the
haircut
because you can't don that no ah well
what a what a tragedy for everyone
[Laughter]
if you fall out in the kim jong-un and
you're gonna you're gonna get it oh
that's great can't go
can i get the uh thick lesbian
from orange is the new black sorry the
the leader is the only one that can get
that wow i think it's more than a caning
though
oh my gosh
love it well in singapore a news report
at the olympics caught singaporeans off
guard
with some uh
a homosexual act uh that uh was in the
background
[Music]
the men were caned and then punished
severely
this was actually the first time
stelter volunteered to do the punishing
he's like how punishment
uh this was this was actually the first
time though that uh many singaporeans
have ever seen two gay men kiss really
so yeah there was some street reactions
[Music]
[Music]
oh you should see what happens when
somebody steps in
[Laughter]
it's gum it's the latest indiana jones
real painful terrible yes
yeah i uh it's actually the first time
i've seen that guy so i was a bit
shocked really
gay men kissing mm-hmm i live in the uh
hallmark world was that say do you not
watch any television at all i live in uh
dean kane never kissed another guy in a
hallmark camp yeah no that's true you
haven't seen like a chase bank ad
because that's relevant
yeah yeah no that's weird you're right
though like every time i look at my
phone it's like oh it's a
it's like three men and a dog i'm like
this is bank of america yeah
this is your ad like i don't understand
i get i get it we should accept people
i'm on board with that but what does
this have to do with banking yeah never
going back to that atm inclusivity ew
yeah
lots of deposits i need to just go in
and just just to make people
uncomfortable and go i
this appear on my phone i need to close
every account i have yeah
i'm just i'm uncomfortable i'm actually
afraid of these people are you
homophobic it's like no i just i just
don't understand your reasoning
i don't like your ad spend
i don't blame them though there is a lot
of disposable income in the gay
community is there yeah okay why that's
why they spruce up neighborhoods you
ever notice that that's why they don't i
don't like that income i don't think
that's why
why well they're decorative people
we can say that right
they're not decorations no they're very
good at they're getting decorating
they're good they're great they're good
they have they have an eye they have
good taste they have an eye for it yeah
okay
called dinks double income no kids yep
oh that's exactly true yep that's right
absolutely well it could be a couple
any couple maybe other meetings as well
yeah it could be a lot of others
they're actually called twink dinks
[Laughter]
i have two jobs all right so
you guys know joe biden the former vice
president former vice president yeah
joseph our bud joseph robinette biden is
that his name robinette
and you know in french tte is the
feminine version of any name yeah and i
think they do it in in spanish as well
no
but it would have been joseph robin
biden would have worked robinette you
know he spent a lot of time in lockers
oh you absolutely i how in the world do
i know the hurt locker that's his middle
name let's get robinette yeah
why would you name someone that that's
weird people have awful names they do
why robinette let's go with that it's
not even a good name for a woman you're
like joe okay that's safe well how do we
screw him up i don't know robinette yeah
yeah throw that in there yeah let's go
with the most basic man name ever yeah
yeah and then just toss in a lady name
right now right yeah and i think that's
why it's kind of like the boy named sue
i think he spent a lot of time fighting
at the bike racks because of that middle
name it toughens you up a little bit
looking for his dad at bars that's right
he killed a man that named me robinhood
everything he just shows up it's his son
pass out
looking for my dad son i knew that name
would make you go to work for the
government for 50 years
on the public dole
and i'm going to name my son hunter
what's his middle name oh no susan
hunter rachel biden
just in case you never know
you gotta do that's what middle names
are now it's an alternate just in case
it's laquisha oh my goodness
hunter is his middle name hunter oh
what's his face his first name is robert
uh hunter's a hunter's middle name
hunter's a bob robert hunter biden he's
one of the bobs he's bob biden
i got a meeting with the bobs
so what do they think they put all this
oh i guess we can't talk about stuff on
youtube that's maybe
whatever i don't know
so bob hunter biden yeah
weird his name and beau biden was joseph
robinette bow biden oh my god he did
robinette to him too he's a big fan of
beau bridges geez
and jackson he did robin that to him
wait wait this is joseph robinette bow
binding
except for you hunter well we don't know
what the hell to do with i
don't want to give you my strong lady
name that i've carried that's right
we start with joseph a strong masculine
name yeah yeah yeah we insert femininity
right in the softening yes and then we
do it again and again we create legacy
[Laughter]
there's one guy watching this whose name
is robinette it's so pissed that's it
i'm done with this mug club we had one
unsubscribed just now
yeah literally just one because no one
would hurt their children like that
i don't know if you heard this the the
biden administration
uh will allocate 30 million dollars
really to help
provide safe smoking kits to
underprivileged communities i'm sorry
what that's correct
including in these kits will be pipes
for users
to smoke substances like crack cocaine
and crystal meth or any illicit
substances
according to reports two 29.5 million
will go directly to joe's son hunter of
course
and well he's tired of giving him the
money for it like i gotta buy a new
crack by every four minutes
uh snopes uh also rated the claim as
mostly false yeah uh saying that this is
just one why don't you read this part
all right so the quote is this was just
one of around 20 components of the grant
program and far from its most prominent
or important one but it's the funniest
one despite being the primary focus of
outraged news reports the purpose of the
program was to reduce the harm and risk
of infection
from a pipe
if among trunk users not to advance
racial equality although that was a
secondary uh consideration
and uh dave dave no no no no no no no
dave come on come on no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no give me give me
what give me the pen it's just it's
give me this over give me the sober no
come on come on no no little hit off the
glass deck day one
i don't want to
come on the government gave it to me
with four cobia dresses
they sent that to your house huh yeah it
says it's a pipe for smoking weddings
can i ask a question i understand the
needle exchange program and and you know
maybe making sure people aren't sharing
needles and spreading hiv and you know
all that kind of stuff do you want my
chair the crack pi i do want the chip in
fact we'll take it just put it on the
desk next to the gun okay sorry then i'm
gonna be high on crack for the rest of
the show yeah
help me out here how does giving
somebody a fresh pipe
keep them from getting a disease
i don't know i guess they please smoke
pipe the days in covid i guess they were
like look we don't want you guys to
share
lips oh is this a covet thing i don't
know it's it's a nonsense thing you
don't know where my lips are dave why
would anyone do this why would you send
a crack pipe to a crackhead in the mail
i know i just wanted to help you out
with something yeah well if you're going
to smoke meth use the government-issued
pipes the only way they're really seems
like they're almost condoning it it's
like they're advertising well the good
thing is san francisco in places like
los angeles have already started doing
this stuff on like a local i'm not even
kidding like on a local level they've
already had programs like this in place
and it's just led to a utopian society
right oh it's great there san francisco
wonderful model city it's above it
beautiful right have you been there in
the spring i don't know if you know this
crack san francisco treat ah
i thought it was crap oh well it's a
thing they're both everywhere
it's the stupidest thing in the world
just a street filled with hard opioid
crack dumps
i want to ask snopes to be like yeah
look i get that there are other programs
but uh just to confirm they are giving
away free crack pipes right right
okay their rating service is the best
though yeah mostly false
what's the most late part
it begs so many questions that was true
but there's more information that's
right
i feel in context uh they're free pipes
but
i feel like hunter does have to be doing
something though because in the middle
of all this pandemic all this stuff he's
like guys what about uh free crack pipes
for people yeah easy those things are to
break so come on crack pipes everybody
gets one nobody you know hey you guys
like to party he's the consultant yeah
no we don't we don't hunt her you know
who's loving this every drug pusher out
there he's like ah fantastic oh this is
great free paraphernalia that's great
i'll have more clients i can smoke oh
there he is that's one of the government
issues yeah yeah exactly well he's got a
hunter biden branded one well yeah but
it is
a golden signature on it well he painted
it on it well it's embroidered he goes
the thing's remembered it says don't put
parmesan cheese in this he goes to
things remembered to forget there's a
hunter coat of arms
it's on his towels and his crackpot it
says the rubbernets
[Laughter]
yes
the robinette crackback robin
the only rocket you buy the biden family
yes yes enjoy a too
all three come on who's counting on your
fellow citizens yes
enjoy it every day of your life until
you have to make the choice between
penis or poison
there is a biden
there is a biden coat of arms oh nice
there you go really oh my goodness oh
that's great oh fantastic yes i would
like to paint a track pipe though money
for that i missed that
jeez
it's positively regal our fear
is decadent well that covers for all
your sins yep speaking of sins ooh i
don't know if you know this you know
what nuns are gerald did they fly uh
some do okay well yeah not all of them
but i've met a nun or two you you've met
some nuns never none i've seen them from
afar they kind of float
yeah as a kid i thought they were on
roller skates because they never you
couldn't see the feet but they would
move along in the long run that's what
your brain went through it was like ah
they must have roller skates
it was creepy they appear to be walking
at a normal pace
[Laughter]
well get this a nun was sentenced to
federal prison really yeah it's got to
be crazy a boring place filled with
women
what a what a strange
well it depends on what state
we're talking about well yeah but a nun
was sentenced to federal prison for
stealing
835 000
from a school in los angeles
sister mary clarence oh no i'm sorry
just sister mary will have to turn
herself
into the federal bureau of prison by
june 7th to start her one year and one
day sentence oh and i think guess this
nun didn't think the vow of poverty
applied to her sister mary margaret
cooper is a catholic nun are we playing
hottie or not one year and one day
in prison prosecutors say the 80 year
old nun embezzled over
835 thousand dollars from st james
catholic school in torrance california
and what is an undoing with that much
money trips to las vegas
gambling expenses according to sister
mary's plea agreement
wow
she just really loved sister act and
wanted to see it live yeah that should
really be uh
should really be uh going to
good things for the catholic church like
lawyers it's the perfect cover did you
see her yeah
i would ever have suspected she she when
they confronted her she said well nuns
need raises we're not paid enough yeah
it's such a
it's such an addiction too though yeah
like i get it like she went a little bit
crazy yeah yeah yeah and 835 grand later
they were like did you take something
who's the accountant here that's like
mike tyson with don king yeah yeah cause
i bought like a bike what happened yeah
yeah you got 50 million dollars later
they went to buy a sandwich and they're
like your car declined
what
but i got three tigers at home watching
plasma tvs not no
move
i don't know
[Laughter]
now you might say that she's being
heretical j heretical radical would be a
good word yeah heretic yeah heretic and
you'd probably be right
but we think she may have been reading
an alternate version of the bible we
actually have a story from what we think
is the same bible and we'd like to share
it with you
isn't it wonderful
in all the years we've been married
you've done some marvelous things this
however
is truly a miracle thank you nama
whatever whatever your name mrs noah i
love you mrs noah and i love you oh
shall we
yes
[Applause]
oh boy
that
is a lot of [ __ ]
i'm leaving you
[Music]
that's a fact tearjerker in that ending
it really is i wonder which one of uh uh
her sons she left before
listen
to the other two people on earth right
come on no
no there were other family members they
had they had sons and daughters who had
wives and husbands so they could just
sleep with them oh good so that you're
right my inbreeding joke was way off
yeah
not even close
no no don't you realize that you know
russell crowe had to kill all of the the
babies being born there so yeah that was
oh yeah you know whatever that movie was
i had a friend mm-hmm we call them
pictures gerald they're pictures uh
that's actually there did you see the
russell crowe picture the talkies oh i
thought it was a little too much
i'm a gladiator and now he's noah i buy
it every time have you seen fatty
arbuckle fall down in the new picture ah
it's hilarious for my money it's that
buster keaton it was like the train was
coming right at me
like an asian in the subway tracks
are we still on youtube i think well how
could we not be said nothing that was
fake no no not at all that's a fact
check that
out
snopes us
i've angry mostly false i've angered you
yeah mostly false you've not angered me
at all i'm never angry
i think life is not about anger it's not
i mean the beginning of the show with
the showtime thing
angers you a little well
just because it's like are you just
trying to make people racist yeah like
is that the goal of today is just to
separate everyone completely to the it
is they're like let's get some people on
to say the most racist things possible
and call it good yeah
my friend's dad anyway had webb feet
yeah really and yeah swimmer
yeah exactly
and that's why the noah's ark thing made
me think of it because if anybody's
gonna
build a boat
now would be him but
he also had lactating nipples and it's
like why would you wow why would you
tell your friends that like they're not
going to make fun of you forever he had
like is that the thing yeah yeah man can
i have like that yeah for look it up
lactating that i have nipples milk
migraines
but his middle name wasn't robinette so
he's fine yeah but he told us like we
wouldn't make fun of him
dave you say it's a matter of fact yeah
it's like yeah my friend's dead yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
it was crazy that he told us is that
true token island yeah men can have like
examples
i i want to i want to know and this is
like an actual scientific thing not a
thing we just allow now because
everything's stupid well no right like
this isn't like bleeding right this
isn't no no no no no milk happens to
marathoners right and i believe they're
called actually milk ducks
with which is ironic for ducts
with a t with a t yes but it still
sounds like ducks and he had webbed feet
[Laughter]
i learned so much on this show
look it up i want to see it i want him
he's looking he's being he's looking at
the screen very closely we'll see
the reaction what was that it's real
right okay yeah all right i told you are
you gonna show us something yeah windows
right you wanna see i don't think it's
gonna be gruesome all right well it
a zit do you pop it i wonder how he
found out
i just i'm just in the mirror one day
and was like oh yeah oh wow
his boyfriend probably found it so that
was a that was a a male person a male
person who is born milk ducks okay i'm
just
no you have every right i am asking
simple questions you have every right
that 10 years ago what is the occurrence
of the population of that though uh
gibby it's got to be right oh i only
knew the one
anecdotally
well look in a pinch if there's a you
know a famine you know who to go for
well that's true that's another reason
though why he could be the new noah
because if he's stranded at sea he has
chest nourishment
and animals to eat chest i guess you'd
probably eat an animal before you i
would i would definitely eat an animal
you drank your own milk
it seems like a waste of effort that'd
be weird he never goes to the store to
get milk but he always has a milk
mustache
imagine when they had their first kid
he's like honey no no you've done enough
i'll take this one no please
yeah let me go ahead and breastfeed told
you i wanted to be a part of this yes i
want him to grow up to be a monster
i've always wanted a serial killer as a
child yeah i think hitler's father also
had
milk
come taste daddy's milk
that's why they're all from wisconsin
america's dairyland
why do you think it is all the serial
killers are from wisconsin that's true
yeah you're just at his house eating a
sandwich what kind of cheese is this
it's homemade homemade yeah yeah
fantastic oh
you don't seem to have a dairy farm of
sorts no no no no no no just finish the
sandwich and we'll talk about it
tastes good huh it tastes okay
it's pretty well documented in male
fruit bats
and then in in humans it's very rare i'm
trying to
but it happens it does it does happen
well we've seen it you know heard about
it and uh we are all dumber for that and
his dad's name was arthur fruit bat
ah well that makes sense
listen eating bats just a bad idea
across the board doesn't matter what
kind no we've if we've learned anything
in the last couple years bats not the
best food options a good food item at
all now i have you ever
have you seen a bat like at night oh
yeah creepy i would never eat that i
would never
hit it with a tennis racket though
[Laughter]
that's all that's like not really fair
they can't see it coming dave
no they're not aren't they nocturnal
yeah but they can't see they're blind
bats are blind they use sonar haven't
you seen batman come on what's the
matter yeah but i didn't think that was
bats i thought it was batman
batman's not blind batman
i've heard blind as a bat but i thought
they had where did you think it came
from
oh one bat that was blind and had a cane
why would you choose that as your
superhero then i have no idea it's
that's more daredevil well that blind
guy that was stupid yeah why is
everybody blind i don't know absurd
so anyway speaking of blind and absurd
caitlyn jenner
has announced this
the gender racing team
you know
the lady who killed a guy with her
maybe this time she'll uh maybe this
time she'll hit someone else and turn
back into bruce
no stop signs on the uh racetrack
all good
nothing to run yeah just go
yes it just goes from
bruce to mrs doubtfire to boys don't cry
just keep switching plots
yeah the team will compete in the w
series an international single-seater
motor racing championship for female
drivers
jenner will oversee the daily operation
of the team which will compete in may we
actually have obtained exclusive footage
of the all-female team drivers training
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my goodness they're doing good so far
i'm not so bad yeah it's not too bad
thank god for walls and fences yes
we're gonna we're gonna see gail
earnhardt
so we
[Laughter]
get your collector's plates while you
can
could you imagine a bruce jenner caitlyn
jenner collector's plate for racing
you're like i'm not eating office
not with that face looking at me not
eating your cheese nipple sandwich off
this gross plate what world am i living
in i want to shatter anything once you
go through my wrist your webbed footed
freak
but back to the fun
it's all racing though there's no no
parallel parking or anything no thank
god okay yeah yeah if it's parallel
parking championship you just
what do you think it'll be a long day i
think you just would have to call it
well when someone's trying to austin
powers this thing into a space for the
next
30 minutes
you got to kind of wave it off
uh everybody lost
so i guess everybody won
it's just yelling at a man while he's
parallel parking that's the whole sport
turn the wheel it's like you don't know
how to do this
you don't drive anywhere i'm holding
this space for my husband move on yeah
please go
oh
is ca i wonder if caitlin's gonna be the
judge
there's no judges
in racing is there not not really it's
all about no it's all about the
checkered flag well somebody says who
wins though well that's typically
determined by who crosses the line first
well i know but there has to be somebody
this isn't figure skating david they
call the race though they're our style
points they call the race i only know
figure skating
there's no east german judge anymore
dave
well you know what i mean the ref yeah
um
also non-existent
i was thinking that's got a i was
looking at a foot locker the other day
the guy's dressed as a ref
they're always like that and you gotta
think that their son's like my dad's a
referee and then one day they're gonna
be like oh man
i really want that dead go to work with
dad day we're going to a field somewhere
right no yeah no son i i lied i'm gonna
spray stuff into sneakers all day
i'm gonna sell a pair of jordans to a
guy who's going to get shot in the
parking lot for him
yeah you're not going to own these long
[Laughter]
are you buying these for someone else
kinda
[Laughter]
now winnipeg uh this is very uh sad
there was uh uh man david uh
alexander
zigarik that's pretty close was charged
uh after intentionally striking four men
with a car during the anti-lockdown
protest
in canada
there's no sound on this but okay oh
there's no so we can do it yeah there he
goes oh yeah just total it seems like a
normal yeah normal there's a
oh disgusting awful
yeah
it's the most violent thing that's
happened at the protest by the way
it's just sad i guess you thought tim
hortons was going to close in 10 minutes
he actually tim horton he was leaving
tim hortons
he's trying to get to a bathroom
unfortunately
[Laughter]
fortunately nobody was killed and
sincerely i mean that i think it's an
absolute shame that people are doing
this it's disgusting
and bo and one man was sent to the
hospital uh as a result of his injuries
we actually if you read that in canadian
he was sent to hospital i sent a
hospital to hospital he was sent he was
on holiday and was sent to the hospital
sent to hospital she's on holiday and
sent to hospital that's right but to be
true you know kind of true to form in
canada he was sent to the hospital for a
sprained ankle and died yes so 11 days
later he was seen for dehydration
he right angled his leg and was seen
four days ago yeah he died of thirst
like the guy in tremors
he's been discharged folks we can make
fun of it because he's out of the
hospital now okay oh no he's fine that's
a good thing nobody was killed like
i guess
those kilometers they they think they're
going faster than they are
i don't think that was the problem there
yeah i think
the setting of the car speed what was he
driving
well it was it was it looked like a jeep
it was a jeep i would assume the saturn
thank you a few car guys in michigan are
like good one yeah
like i don't get it
because they built them over in canada
ah remember the saturn i do southern
states too didn't they remember it went
away i think they did it in southern
state briefly too yeah no saturn's
around anymore thank god they're like a
plymouth
yeah you can't get one of those you
don't want one of those at one time you
did not nemo and then they made neon and
the duster my friend had a duster he put
subwoofers in the back
it had tents and furry seats you felt
like hey couldn't you have spent more on
the car itself and maybe yeah no it was
great i loved riding with him and
getting pulled over every 12 minutes
yeah
getting searched for drugs did he loosen
the trim so that the base and the
subwoofers would
vibrate everything oh
no they actually the
screw turned on all the trip yeah the
base did it for him actually yeah yeah
some old some all the old cars look so
oh they're great yeah the muscle cars
yeah they're so beautiful and remember
the things you could actually work on
before uh the computers
they were great going going in the
straightaway the minute you tried to
turn well
laughing
in men it kept us stronger and as far as
airbags they were really just
decapitation
they're like look you're gonna end up
you're you're gonna end up on life
support we'll just we'll just make this
incredibly unsafe so it'll just kill you
yeah
yeah i had a mustang
5.08 i don't think it had airbags
but yeah i knew if i got an accident
it's just goodbye
but it was fun to drive like why would i
wear this seat belt yeah
why would i do that really no reason we
don't worry stinking headrests it was it
was a drop top so really like what if i
flip what am i gonna do yeah so those
were so overpowered for what they could
handle oh they really were too yeah you
could feel the nuts and bolts shaking
off of the fox body
we uh but anyway we're getting off track
that's what happens back to mr ziggurat
yeah because this was a ziggurat's a
much funner conversation
is uh he he is a former member uh of the
winnipeg-based and self-styled anti-punk
band
punk oh i thought it was oh yeah
oh i'm sorry i thought
antifa punk band yeah cool guy
the brat attack
so you
god
wow when you have to call yourself a
brat just throw it in your mouth anti
yeah rat attack with rats and he was
also uh yeah
the brat attack
uh the band was pretty innocent uh when
they first got together here's a sample
of one of their first songs
[Applause]
[Music]
right doesn't sound punk to me i could
be off no it's a little osman dish but
you know whatever that's definitely an
unbuckle the seat belt kind of song yeah
yeah i mean
it's a little it's a little rebellious
because it's like no matter what you
tell us government we're friends forever
let's do our secret handshake
by the way always wear your seatbelt yes
[Laughter]
um which is different now uh
the the the band's leader songs got a
bit darker
uh with with one called uh
hey harper you homophobe anti-choice f
die die die ah
this is in reference to stephen harper
the conservative canadian politician and
former prime minister
some of the lyrics were
uh
this is class war you rich white f
ruling classes [ __ ] out of luck your god
is effing dead i shot him in the head
friends forever jumping on the bed
[Applause]
i mean yeah he turned but i mean they
were still friends they were so i think
that's important that the government
couldn't tear him apart about friendship
dave yeah about friendship
the power of
his
wind water friendship friendship
friendship
his band even played a warp tour
really war of tour but then fell apart
in 2005. i don't know how that would
have happened
we're still talking about the guy that
ran over the body yeah yeah yeah right
okay yeah yeah all right yeah detailing
his music trying to keep it okay all
right yeah we just but there's a few
darker things that we get into here he
uh
zurich has also been accused of sexual
assault by victims uh on tumblr he's uh
tumblr uh yet well this was a while ago
oh it wasn't
it wasn't today
uh he uh
he was a pedo ah yeah that's that's what
it is that's why his new song pedo
forever
no not quite the same yeah best friends
forever whether you want it or not to
get you in my van
i hope you like candy all right so
[Laughter]
one victim wrote this is gonna be fun to
read
back in 2005 when i was 13 i was just
getting into the winnipeg punk scene who
wasn't
this person was a hero of mine he played
one of my favorite in one of my favorite
local bands the brat attack and
contributed greatly to my political
opinions
he initiated beginning
a sexual relationship with me over the
internet asking me questions about my
sexual activity sending me pictures of
his body telling me that because he was
an anarchist he didn't believe
that age dynamics were relevant oh so
that's a good pickup line
at the time
at the time he was 27 at 13 i just
wanted to be taken seriously and
respected i wanted him to like me
oh so obviously just a man having a
tough moment and he ran people over not
no history of yeah
they didn't have sex forever they didn't
it was just sex the one time
[Laughter]
was that his defense to the court yeah
he sang he brought in everybody
he brought in
look i was gonna let you go until you
started singing he's like guys let me
explain i'm i'm an anarchist so ready
hitter
but it was a girl making the accusation
i believe it was a girl making the
accusations so uh he's not some kind of
gay freak
i didn't say that i got quite a puncture
up there winnipeg
i was just 13 getting into winnipeg punk
who doesn't snowy
snowy nights terrible music
and now he's mowing down freedom
fighters with us
yeah great human being
i just find that so sad the internet is
anti-freedom
yeah it is the internet is just the
worst
i'm tired of people going well you know
it's a necessary evil no it's just
unnecessary
yeah this should just be a show on
television
let's get rid of it we've taken the
internet we don't deserve it we've
proven it's a toy that we can't handle
it should be taken away and put up on
top shelf like a teacher would do and be
like you guys can have this back when
it's not
just awful it goes in the teacher's
drawer with the chattering teeth yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and the
exactly
you don't get the internet back until
you can learn to behave yourself
everything is porn
knock it off
i'm not even saying don't do porn you be
do porn
stop it
i'm not saying you should do porn
i'm not saying you just said you be you
well if that's you i can't help it
i'm so confused what is your platform
that you're running i just don't want to
throw stones
no no we can call out like bad things
though and say hey stop it hey speaking
of calling out bad things yeah i'm gonna
need you to ready the admonish button
because we got this from josh
admonish gerald bats are not blind
this is from
usgs.gov are that's blind no bats are
not blind that's not true bats are blind
buyers
i want to fact check that maybe not all
bats are blind yeah but where did blind
does the bag come from then huh no
well they use that they use that sonar
right to navigate at night yeah but
sound travels way slower than light
so they're at a disadvantage wouldn't
they be
yeah they seem to be doing fine oh i
figured it out but now what
evolutionists
has been working on but yeah you think
we're eons you think batman was i don't
think batman was blind though
bruce played it very well i don't think
he was blind and he
gerald's over here just endlessly saying
that bruce wayne was clearly the blind
guy what was wayne enterprises anyway do
we know what he did to his koch brothers
it became like military equipment was
something that they produced yeah
weapons no real cool stuff in the
beginning though was other
i believe it was other stuff trinkets
yes mostly watches bobble heads yeah
chia pet was real big for them huge for
them i have a richard simmons chia pet
i do
are you serious yeah will you bring it i
haven't taken it out of the box much
like who's ever keeping him captive but
i do have it
he's he's
he's actually a fan richard simmons oh
is he yeah he's okay i think that dude's
fun i think steven's had some
correspondence with him
yeah i do have a richard simmons chia
pet for real sweat into the oldies
you put the the thing in the hair gross
move grooving i figured it would yeah i
guess that's true it won't be the chest
he says ew shapes this is gross well
so i'm going to take one that should
definitely blind i hate all of you
we're going to look this up we're going
to confirm this
some mice can be blind
helen keller was blind at least three of
them and deaf
fine fine you're right batman was blind
dave thank you yeah
i don't want to get off on the scam that
is helen keller but sorry guys it's not
what you think no it's a lady completely
lying about what she was saying oh wow
yeah the woman is blind and deaf and
like ish you think she was blindish
i just i cause honestly if you're blind
and deaf and all you have is touch it
was a bit of a parlor trick yeah
there's no way you could learn english
[Laughter]
i just don't get it i don't believe you
would be able to communicate
like i believe
zeroes in on the point there's no way
well i believe like when she was young
she could communicate the way she did by
throwing plates and acting like an
animal
then that makes sense if that's not
angry
yeah because you'd be pissed every day
you'd be like i don't know anything but
touch how mad would you be well you
wouldn't have any reference for it yeah
well you wouldn't have any reference for
anything though you just
you wouldn't know what anything is i
mean if you're born that way you
wouldn't have a loss you wouldn't have
ever had it
but you
it would still suck i'm not saying it's
a good thing imagine how they envision
the world you don't even know i don't
they just picture whatever they think
something looks like and i bet it's all
wrong
i think that's the least of the problems
though
but if you're like that was a plate you
play piano
you get well
that's a good trade-off if you gotta if
you got to make the trade
dude stevie wondering ray charles
amazing yeah amazing
which brings us to the end of our show
well no well just the end of this well
yeah we're gonna go to my club we're
gonna play a little game because we do
actually people say that we're like uh
can be trans-phobic and that kind of
stuff and we're gonna go ahead in the
mud club and prove that that's not true
with a little game called
a hot or not
and uh i think you guys should too what
addition is that uh it's the uh
transgender
oh that's what you're alluding to
or not uh so it's the same level of
judgment that we would give anyone else
it's equality and uh we feel that you
will enjoy the segment
uh please tune in i i tried to pitch
that as innocently as possible you did a
good job we're still on youtube oh
that's good yeah
oh god well i didn't say anything about
that you can cast off all restraint you
can say a transgender person is
attractive on youtube can't you do that
you can for sure you just can't do that
you probably will yeah i mean
i imagine you can i don't know that i
want to play this game if it's that
great isn't that most detergent
commercials
like isn't that everything now you're
like oh this is eco waffles lego my ego
oh you're transgender oh you can have it
i had no idea
no idea that bulge in your pants
my friend's transgender izzy or wait
sorry or whichever way uh
he became a she okay so is she
yeah interesting i think the game should
be blair white and everyone else yeah
blair white yeah there's definitely she
takes it to a beautiful yeah she's a
beautiful girl met blair white yeah
great yeah it's true
you uh have total buy-in what do you
gerald uh
definitely convincing
okay yeah see
and i think that's that should be the
line it's like app you put a lot of
effort and work into that i wouldn't be
able to tell you you're not going to
miss
misname her no no you would not i said
her you would never misgender her no no
i would never mispronoun her i would
never and i think her name was blair
without the e kind of like robinette
without ah oh really that wasn't a huge
change i think so that's just asking for
it
well
so guys go ahead smash the like button
tell us that you enjoyed the show we
really appreciate you listening today i
want to thank
uh crawdaddy for stepping in as usual
and of course gerald a coming in every
day working hard does a lot of push-ups
very cruel to the staff but other than
that good guy well they deserve it well
it's true and i i just think reading
passages to them from the bible
completely out of context is strange
while beating them well you are you have
one book for hitting in one book for
real my name is the law it was all about
control vengeance upon me
may i have a sip of your beverages
anyway join us
until then piss off youtube and smash
the like button piss off youtube